European ministers responsible for
telecommunications will debate this week
ways to limit mobile telephone roaming
charges and barriers to service
providers doing business across the EU
the debate is part of efforts to improve
regulation of the telecommunications
sector and is aimed at helping to
increase competitiveness in Europe as
the digital economy grows the sector
could also develop into a major employer
particularly of young people The
ministers will examine other proposals
from the European Commission to improve
consumer protection standardized
products for operators to smooth their
entry onto the market and limits on
telephone call charges the proposals if
adopted by the council and the European
Parliament would help to complete the
digital single market by 2015 ministers
will also assess the progress made on
improving air passenger rights the
Commission has proposed ways to clear up
gray areas on rules concerning the
rights of people whose flights are
delayed or cancelled and to boost
complaint handling regulations but the
goal is also to limit the burden on
airlines in part by dealing with the
high costs that some of these
obligations might impose on carriers in
exceptional circumstances
you